[Musik]
das immer schon ab zehn kinder auch wenn
zum banken geht die sollte man lieber
nicht abziehen weil sonst noch immer im
gefängnis
aber erst mal herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu einem neuen blog meine damen
und herren ich bin luca und ich gehe
jetzt voll spaß verrät die rede schon
anhand der umgebung hier im blog meine
damen und herren ich bin wieder zurück
in quellen golfurlaub ich habe trotzdem
immer noch ein bisschen sonnenbrand so
das aber gar nicht weiter stören denn
ich bin locker der welt auf ganz youtube
und deswegen habe ich natürlich auch
immer passende geile ideen am start für
die blogs zum beispiel habe ich ein
bällebad ist es so verflixt es bei geht
und zu lieben ich würde allerdings sagen
wir fragen erst mal fluffy wie es ihm
überhaupt heute so geht ok war eine
super unterhaltung mit gedanken dafür
wenn ihr wollt dass ich diesen kleinen
fleck ja dann lass mal bitte ein
leichter wenn ich schlafe ich öfter im 1
ja ich glaube die leute wissen es
langsam dringt seht ihr es bereits im
titel eine meine damen und herren du
laut nichts und heute auf die idee
gekommen weil wir uns gerade
essen bestellt haben wurde dort das
ganze gerade oben auf wieso baut man
essen auf ist ja auch egal
auf jeden fall haben wir beiden uns
gedacht hey man bestellt sich eigentlich
wirklich immer nur es doch dass man
gerade bock hat und was vielleicht eine
ganz gute bewertung hat weil man die
anderen nutzern vertraut und anderen
bestellen allerdings was ist wenn man
einfach mal das gegenteil macht und sich
essen bestimmt was einfach einen stern
hat und worauf man gar kein bock hat
deswegen meine damen und herren
bestellen wir beiden uns heute erst mal
hallo juli
wie geht es dir mir gehts scheiße weil
ich dich gerade gesehen habe also das
essen haben wir uns jetzt gerade hier
bestellt irgendwie so lax mit kartoffeln
und irgendwie so ein nachtisch und 2000
fort allerdings ja ich glaub dir zu
sagen damit bestellt uns heute essen was
nur ein stern hat zuvor essen wir
allerdings erst mal ich weiß nicht warum
aber unsere nachbarn haben irgendwie ein
stuhl draußen hängen
[Musik]
es war wirklich sehr lecker muss ich an
welches zu geben aber das ist die battle
war dass meine presse wenn ich wirklich
gespannt wie es sein wird wenn wir essen
bestellt oder ist das jetzt
beispielsweise einen stern haben dann
bestellen was zu essen wohl auch gar
keinen bock drauf haben also dass man
ein handy im bällebad steckt mein handy
gerade
[Musik]
es ist halt ein richtiges schritt wetter
heute siri wird es heute schietwetter
geben ist die vorhersage für heute das
widget wetter ob da wir kommen gerade
aus dem sommer oder von der nordsee
zurück sind wieder in köln und bonn
direkt kommt gewitter aber entweder da
wir freuen uns super und wir sind wieder
zurückgekommen ist müssen wir die ganzen
koffer auspacken das gut ist also mein
gott du hast schlug auf das gute freunde
als youtuber wenn man aus dem urlaub
zurückkommen man hat ja noch im kopf
herum liegen haben einfach einen trick
machen und zwar macht man etwas so und
ihr seht schon die koffer sind leer
ich habe gerade etwas im internet
entdeckt wo ich mir einfach nur dachte
sogar darauf musst du reagieren obwohl
luca ich muss euch mal was zeigen
das hat mir einfach ein fan geschenkt
das ist eine kerze die einfach den namen
luca trägt auf jeden fall habe ich
allerdings gerade einen beitrag im
internet gesehen und zwar dass katja
einen neuen song raus bringen wird und
meine damen und herren ich wäre ja nicht
luca wenn ich nicht auch auf diesen song
von katja reagieren würde also sonntag
14 uhr kommt meine reaktion auf den
neuen song von katja allerdings war ich
erst mal zum friseur eine ewigkeit bis
drei stunden sind vergangen freunde wir
waren beim friseur wir fahren in der
buchhandlung bücher kaufen wir waren in
supermarkt wir waren dem boden falls ihr
euch fragen warum gerade soviel
geräusche kamen das aber juli neben bei
der orangen aufgemacht hat judith
übrigens aus wie ein engel einfach ich
auch als mainhausen auch klar geworden
also sehen an den seiten außerdem die
von vorne
und so sehen hier also sie noch ein
bisschen blonder geworden ich dachte mir
einfach mal so hey ich mache mir die
haare bisschen blonder beziehungsweise
nicht ich sondern der friseur ungefähr
hat an der stelle
[Musik]
hey was hast du eigentlich für bücher
gekauft kein problem leut ich sag's euch
michael lewis the big short dann
souverän investieren mit indexfonds etf
daniele maske und aktien für dummies
weil ich bin domin in der tat ich habe
richtig bock ein bisschen mehr wieder zu
lesen
aber das ist ein anderes thema meine
damen und herren denn ihr seht es
bereits im titel eingeblendete vier
bestellung sollte essen mit nur einem
stern bzw
versuchen wir überhaupt erst mal dass
songs zu finden die nur einen stern
haben weil ich denke halt so wenn ich
sowas wäre wie lieferando lieferheld wie
dorade level keine ahnung was da sonst
noch alles gibt nicht wieder alle
restaurants rausschmeißen wir uns zwei
sternen sind weil dann ist es einfach
kacke die leute wollen nicht bestellen
allerdings langsamer fährt nach hinten
wo man da das gebiet gilt das noch mal
wir schauen jetzt mal ob wir einen
restaurant finden was wirklich nur einen
stern hat bzw komplette gruppen
schlechte bewertungen ich werde
selbstverständlich den restaurant namen
et cetera alles zensieren weil wir
wollen ja hier keine rufmord betreiben
oder sowie befinden uns jetzt hier bei
der lieferservice website
ich habe nur mist und balken beginnt
audi gleich ein balken deine presse die
cadooz vergessen hat er im computer die
aufnahme zu starten
aber naja also der luca da zeigt was er
bestellt hat ich habe die speisen zu
ende ausgewirkt und leute wirklich ich
muss sagen ist relativ günstig also 20
euro für schnitzel wiener art runde
pizza margherita und seelachsfilet ist
das kann nicht gut schmecken
allerdings würde ich sagen wir klicken
mal auf zur kasse gehen und ich bestelle
das ganze erstmal und dann sehen wir uns
wieder wenn das ganze angekommen ist
[Musik]
was alles um 120 euro besteht schnitzel
wiener art mit pommes eine pizza
margherita ein seelachsfilet mit pommes
zwei beilagensalat und ein curry
dressing ist es gar kein curry das
joghurt oder irgendwie sowas ich hab
ahnung vom kochen ja was geht jetzt
erste gerade essen für einen sternen
leute und ich würde sagen das machen wir
jetzt auch mal also ich fange mal direkt
an der pizza margherita weil ich schon
so perfekt geschnitten ist erstmal man
muss sagen es sieht echt lecker aus die
sportbar okay also eine stinknormale
bestellte pizza ein bisschen zu viel
käse aber ich glaube das ist
geschmackssache nun das rezensionen zur
pizza meine damen und herren liebe
wahrheit im früheren leben war köcheln
job sehr fertig ich glaube das kommt
echt für den film ja also dass die ultra
fertig ist mir auch schon aufgefallen
aber es geht klar oder
ja es vollkommen in ordnung wir nun zu
etwas was man eigentlich gar nicht was
das verkaufen kann und was eigentlich
jeder ist auch relativ gut wenn nicht
was sind die pommes weil schlechtere
bommels als mcdonald's und burger king
bundes gibt es eigentlich nicht
vollkommen normale pornos in ordnung bei
der erstellung stadt nicht mal dabei
dass die pommes wie beim stütze der
weisen ob beim bdr ich dachte das sind
wirklich und schlüssel für den preis
aber komplett auch zum schnitzel packen
wir ja schön ketchup drauf normalerweise
ist wir haben sogar preis zu hören
probier's mal mit ketchup
[Musik]
deutsche läufer wird schon sehr zäh
normaler alte zeiten damit nicht nur
richtig gutes wiener schnitzel essen
wird halt mal schon über 420 euro würde
ich sagen so ab 20 euro geht es
eigentlich gut bloß schön mit reife
werden hier das schnitzel und ab nein da
habe ich mit einem feld bei mir ganz im
ernst für 650 kann sich nicht beschweren
in meinem kleinen snack dabei kommen
vorletzten bzw eigentlich schon zum
letzten mal sich gestellt aber den
verrate ich noch mal probieren im see da
spielen natürlich auch mit ketchup
wir haben keine andere so sowie von
nordsee oder so schwarz ja ganz schön
lautet also ich glaube diesen
beilagensalat ihm müssen wir jetzt nicht
auch über den probieren das wird den
standard beilagensalat seien hier sogar
mit meisten lose magst du doch besonders
gern ich bin ganz ehrlich ich habe
erwartet dass wenn wir jetzt bei einem
lieferservice von 300 restaurants es aus
wenn das wirklich die wenigsten sterne
hat die am schlechtesten bewerteten
rezensionen das ist viel schlimmer
schmecken wird so dass die pizza
irgendwie total verbrannt sein wird und
seelachsfilet irgendwie von innen wird
schon irgendwie am spring ist oder keine
ahnung aber ich bin krass positiv
überrascht besonders wiener schnitzel
geht echt klar für 650 die pommes und
auch vollkommen ok und die pizza alter
die kostet bei anderen liefern
restaurant ist locker irgendwie das
doppelte und schmeckt genauso also leute
lasst euch von rezensionen nicht
beeindrucken natürlich sind rezensionen
wichtig wenn man sich irgendwas kauft
und bestellt damit man halt guckt ok
andere leute die das auch gekauft haben
dies auch konsumiert haben wie stehen
sie dazu wie hat es den geschmeckt die
rede great job getan gab bei mir nude
yoga allerdings da ich ja nur essen
bestellt habe was nur mit einem stern
bewertet so dass wir davon halten wenn
wir uns allgemein mal produkte wie bei
amazon oder so bestellen würden die nur
einen stern haben in den user
bewertungen last einen daumen hoch da
meine damen und herren und bei 40.000
dort sehe ich auf jeden fall dass jeder
bock drauf hat geschmeckt für die wolken
sehen will chinas hallo wolken hat der
[Musik]
bruder der toten um die wohl stellung
auch ich würde an dieser stelle der
heutigen block 3
an der stelle treten
machst du das sie extra an dieser stelle
vision heutigen doch jetzt auch beenden
meine damen und herren ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen dass jude und ich einfach
mal essen bestellt haben was wirklich
die geringsten also die schlechteste
bewertung hatte dies gibt ja dessen
eltern schule hier in denen regal
ich trag schuhe schreibt in die
kommentare banane wenn ihr vortrag und
april wenn ihr keine schuhe trage also
auf zur nächsten da hinten wie ich
bereits gesagt habe freut euch auf den
block am sonntag dann am sonntag um 14
uhr werde ich auf den neuen song von
katja glaser mit reagieren ich weiß noch
nicht was mich erwarten wird aber ich
würde sagen wir sie müssen am sonntag
wieder hat euch lieb
[Musik]
doch